uh yeah I think uh it is kind of crazy
because I do feel like
you were kind of like
you had a crazy run bro because you
ended up going super viral doing the
fashion show working with X how did
you when X initially link up DMs like
that pretty much I looked up to X like
my whole career like that was my
favorite artist you know what I'm saying
and
I would DMO and then he hit me back like
but the way he hit me bad was like he
knew me like it was my friend already
you know what I'm saying and when we
would chop it up he would just tell me
so much like info on like just like what
to do and like how to do it like write
out your own deals all that type of
like just real grown game you know what
I'm saying like big bro you funny
but we never met but we always chop it
up on online on DM like we would
FaceTime for hours though you feel me
like just talking you get what I'm
saying like play the game together all
that type of and then but we never
met but we were all and I was sending
music he was sending me and then
we made the song and he put it on the
album it was like three people in that
album you know what I'm saying was it
huge was Joey Badass on there yeah and
Travis uh Parker yeah no that's crazy
that is wild because that is a important
album in history now we look back
because that was his first like that was
his first album yeah no it was well it
wasn't that his first full-length album
no it was maybe Bruno said was it 17 or
the question mark 17 was his first okay
then it was a question mark because
a question mark was on uh well he was
always dropping project like right from
the jump like little mini projects and
stuff like that but yeah his full first
project was 17 I'm pretty sure do you
remember what your last like exchange
with him was before he passed away
probably a FaceTime call you know we
would just chop it up I would send a
music you know I would send him a song I
was sending him the song I was working
on it for him he was supposed to hop on
because when we did the um
song for his album it was like a swap so
he would give me one for my vice versa I
was supposed to have another song but we
never got it done damn man yeah tell me
the story about Drake trying to buy one
of your records oh so the reason I
didn't do that was because I was cool
with X you go what I'm saying and like
and there was that kind of like weird
beef that they had that going on so
I just stayed out the way of that and
then on top of that I linked that with
um my boy like Boogie pretty much so he
could just get the beat and now they got
it so what was it so it was it it was a
so Drake was trying to buy a song that
you had already like cut yeah I already
made it it was called message and uh my
manager pretty much told me my manager
at that time told me that
uh they was trying to buy the song
for
150 000 and
I just denied it because it was like how
to respect the X yeah I respect the X
and then
you know it was just
it was like pick a side you know what
I'm saying choose your side you know
what I'm saying and I just
I mean he did a solid for you put you on
his album that's my brother too you know
what I'm saying beyond all that so I
just had to stay down for that you feel
me but yeah and now you say that
producer's got tons of musical Drake
yeah that's crazy yeah yeah do you ever
feel like you get it I'm on a jumbo
trial song If you hear it's uh you know
what I'm talking about you hear my tag
in that song do you feel like you get
enough credit in terms of like some of
the like could you I feel like you were
ahead of the curve yeah I mean
credit is credit bro if if people want
to give me credit that's cool my ego
done being dissolved and die like I
don't even exist bro like artists is a
figment of your mind you know what I'm
saying all that oh Maddox this big
celebrity I'm a human being I'm just
like everybody else ain't no different
right you know what I'm saying so I
don't need no credit everybody actually
takes influencing
gives influence that's the point of the
game you get what I'm saying we are
vessels at the end of the day so I don't
my credit gonna come you know what I'm
saying whatever credit on they gonna see
they gonna know and people be talking
people be saying they know they know the
real ones know right at least so like
when the people tell oh yeah Maddox made
that sound oh Maddox zero degrees
yeah that's that's the blueprint of what
people is doing right now you know what
I'm saying like a lot of the stuff I was
doing back in the days is a blueprint
it's Prodigy you know what I'm
saying like
a lot of people not on it and people
can't understand it because it's just
two is ahead of time